If you don't know how to ask questions, you can ask live questions, but you could go to holistichealthour.com.
That's our website and that's where you can ask questions right on the website so we'll make sure
that we get them on the live call. So feel free to chat in questions through the chat function,
but we'll jump right away to the questions that were already asked. So let's get going. So first question is
my mother has three, four weeks using the rifle sheet with her cancer protocol. In that time she's
begun experiencing daily diarrhea. Could this be for the body's way of detoxifying? No changes in
supplement or diet. What should she do to alleviate this? So can the rifle machine using cancer
programming? Cancer frequencies cause diarrhea. Well, anything's possible with any physiological change
to your body. So yes, I'd say that is possible. So it could be her body detoxifying. I would start by
putting the bone a little bit farther away from her. I don't know if she's using.
First of all, I don't know who asked this question. So if your mom is a member of ours, a patient's
of ours, then we should probably have a discussion on what else she's taking and what else she's doing.
So I'm not sure who was that asked this question, but that should be the first thing. We want to get
some more data. If it is truly the right and using cancer frequencies in its causing diarrhea,
constipation or other physiological change, then doing either moving the ball a little bit farther
away from your body so you're not getting such direct frequency content, contact looking at other
things in your diet, even though diet and supplements weren't changed, your physiology might be
working better in things that you were doing before that were causing and decreased gut motility.
Maybe you need to back off on. So you want to look at the big picture with anything like this,
and not just from a perspective of, is it the right? So if your mom is down a patient of ours and
she bought a right somewhere else and she's doing cancer frequencies, then do it a case review
with me and we can discuss some of those things. Why be in order? Next question. What could be the cause
of childhood asthma? What do you recommend for a child with seasonal allergy asthma flare ups?
So asthma and childhood asthma is becoming more and more frequent, even adult onset or adolescent
asthma. Person who might be in their 20s, 30s, 40s, who's never had history of asthma before their life
has now developed symptoms of asthma. So what in the world have never had asthma before? Now I have
shortness of breath. When I start to work out or exercise, exercise, it does asthma. So the number one
causes of asthma are toxicity issues. It can be a toxicity from a chemical toxicity from the environment
which were being sprayed in our environment with everything from glyphosates from farms to
things overhead in the airways were being polluted every which way we could possibly think.
The food sensitivities read the dyes in foods are very common issue with asthma. So that's another
toxicity issue when it's toxins that are consumed. Histamine can be an issue with asthma looking at
that person's genes, their HNMT genes, their ability to get rid of histamine in their tissues that can
be an issue with asthma. Chronic lung infections can be an issue with asthma, but with childhood asthma
many times if the child was not vaccinated so they didn't receive those toxins it can be food
sensitivities. So dairy and gluten are often common issues with asthma with children less than six
years old. We don't typically recommend doing food sensitivity testing. We recommend doing a food
elimination diet so try doing you know eliminating the most common foods that would cause an increase
inflammation in the lungs and the airways and in the tissues and that would be started off would be
dairy, gluten, the gluten cross-reactive foods and egg soy. I would get rid of dyes, red dye, green
dye, blue dye, all the dyes in different foods just try to clean up the environment. Another common
issue with childhood asthma can be fire retardants in clothing. Babies clothing I think from a legal
perspective anything that you're going to buy from you know the department store or something like
that is going to have fire retardants in the material and it doesn't just wash out so getting
organic cotton. I know it can be expensive to make these changes but it can really save a person's
life long term. So cleaning out the person's diet, cleaning your house as far as what you're using
for detergents, what you're using for soaps, what you're using for cleaning products,
trying to have a clean environment. You know it's hard because there's fire retardants in your
furniture, you buy a new couch, there's fire retardants in it, new chair, there's fire retardants in
your carpeting. So it's very difficult to try to get rid of this stuff because it's everywhere.
So it can be it can be an expensive endeavor maybe just you know do certain groups at a time to try
to see if that can calm down. If the child is old enough to eat that say they're they're two three
year old or higher using anti-histamine type nutrition. We have a product called ClearHist
Junior that is a chewable quite tasty and natural into histamines that have corset and some things
in it. That can be good for kids. If the child is older and can swallow pills using some anti-histamines
as far as from a natural perspective we have multiple different natural pills, capsule form that
you have to swallow. Certainly you can open those things up and put them in a smoothie as well.
Clean it up the child's diet is going to be a big thing though. Next question.
Using a dog coil, how do you determine the correct frequencies? You can you can waste years
playing around with the wrong ones. Well so a dog coil is usually sold as a frequency generator,
frequency machine to help kill pathogens in live disease. It's very common in the live community
but in truth a dog coil is not really a rife machine. So how I define a rife machine. So a rife
machine is a frequency generator that uses light frequencies. A dog coil to my understanding is
really more of electrical generator which makes it fall into the category of a pulsed electromagnetic
field therapy equipment. So it's more of a PEMF which is great. But then you're not you're not
really concerned about the frequencies. You don't have much play in with a PEMF to play with
the different frequencies. I know different PEMFs you can use different certain different frequencies
but it's in a range that isn't going to be it isn't going to kill pathogens. So what the purpose
of a PEMF machine is to help stimulate your cell membranes, help stimulate your immune system,
your all your cell membranes hold a charge. So your cells have a membrane around them and they
have a charge that is actually measurable. You can actually measure that charge with some
different pieces of equipment. And as a person's cell charge goes down their health gets worse and
worse. There's there's articles written on this. There is much research in the cancer field
with looking at a person's phasing. Oh that's what a measurement of somebody's cell charge is.
And as that person goes through a series of care typically most cancer research is done while
a person is going through you know chemotherapy or a course of standards of care. If their phase
angle remained level through that course of care their chance of survival was much higher than
somebody whose phase angle or cell charge was dropping significantly. So often what a person
is is ill they'll have a lower cell charge with phase angles measured from zero to
about the highest I've seen is about 12. And a normal cell charge or a normal phase angle
in a person is about you want it to be over 6.6. I had people that were fairly healthy even in their
70s that were in the 7s. I used to treat some of the Minnesota Vikings players that had a cell
charge over 10. If you're younger you're going to have a much higher cell charge. But as we age
our cell charge or phase angle drops and as we are become sick for whatever reason our cell charge
could drop. So our phase angle will drop. But if we go if our cell charge is staying level or going
up through a series of care your survival rate is much higher. Well that is a huge benefit of the
PMF. The PMF including a dog coil machine can help people through survival methods through cancer
through Lyme disease because it helps increase one's phase angle. So that can be very helpful. Well
how does that really help? Well if you increase somebody's phase angle you're increasing the
health of their cell membranes. If you increase the health of the cell membranes you increase the
health of the cell. So inside of each cell in your body is literally like
equivalent to New York City. I have everything that's going on in New York City. It's taking place
inside your cell. You have thousands of different organelles and you have of course a nucleus which
you have DNA which then replicate in order to make a new cell. The DNA also codes for making enzymes,
making proteins all sorts of different things that you need for that cell to survive and that cell
to do its job whatever that cell is if it's a muscle cell or a heart cell or whatever it is. So the
health of the cell membrane is utmost importance to the health of what could go on inside that cell.
So as far as getting back to the question how do you know the frequencies to use with a person it
depends on what you're trying to do. So we don't use dog coil machines in our office. We use a different
type of right machine called a true right machine which is very easy to program literally whatever
frequency you want to run within the program of the machine. So there are no frequencies for different
diseases. So let's say if you have prostate cancer you would want to run just the no frequencies for
prostate cancer. You may want to run frequencies for other co-organities that you might have with
prostate cancer maybe inflammation, maybe you have metastasis to all you want some bone-building
frequencies and you maybe you have you know issues with detoxification pathways like everybody
does you might want to run some liver frequencies or key frequencies but you build that around what's
needed for the patient. So there are frequency charts that are available to the public. You could even
google right frequencies. There's documents that are PDF documents that show different frequencies.
Again I don't think you'll be able to really use your dog coil with these frequencies but if you
had a GB 4000 or a true right you could program those frequencies and that's why a person
of staff and let's say they have a specific disease or cancer that will write a specific program that
they'll run literally all night long because these frequencies are magic and it's one big mistake
that people make when they use a right machine or or a PEMF they think that using it for 20 to 30 to
60 minutes a day is going to cure them of their hermality and that's just not true. You're hitting
the body with those frequencies so that you can stimulate a response. In the case of trying to kill
a pathogen with light frequencies you can kill a pathogen directly that when you're dealing with
like cancer you're not killing directly. Cancer cell is your own cell and it's much
sturdier for a sake of a better word than a single cell organism like a bacteria. So you're not
going to kill directly. You're not going to cause lysis of the cell when you hit it with
or you hit a cancer cell with the frequencies that you try to disturb their cancer cell. What you
are doing when you use rife technology light frequencies to help kill cancer you're stimulating
that cancer cells who are in my right so that your immune system will now take another look at it
because that's a huge problem with cancer is that cancer is not an outside organism. Cancer is your
old cells that something got in the cell damaged the nucleus and caused it to go into rapid replication
and it's replicating cells that are also damaged have damaged nuclei in rapid replication. That's
what cancer is. One cell that started rapid replicating and continuing and continuing and continuing
now you have this mass of cells that are damaged have damaged nuclei and are in a state of rapid
replication but they're still cell tissue. Now your immune system is not supposed to destroy
cell tissue. You have a failsafe mechanism for your T cells and your natural killer cells to not
destroy cell tissue. So you have to get the immune system to look at this cancer over and over and
over again until it sees it as an enemy and will destroy it and that's the benefit of using the rife.
You're stimulating those cancer cells so they vibrate so it's an irritation in the body so your
immune system will look at it to try to kill it. So there are no frequencies for many many many different
pathogens. There's no frequencies for different cancers and those are the things that we do in
programming a rife machine. So I do agree you could have the greatest tool in the world like a
frequency generator. If you're not running the right frequencies for your malady it's like a help.
So I think the two best rife machines on the market are the GB 4000 which is much more
difficult to use so we don't typically use that at the true rife which is much easier to use and easier
to program. But again you can run a true rife for let's say a prostate cancer again and if you're
ready there are all the frequencies it's going to do nothing to your prostate cancer so if you're
running just some general cancer frequency set that maybe you got from the company or from a
practitioner who isn't real experienced well it's going to have a little good you know it's going
to do little good. We could never do harm but you're going to do little good and well that doesn't
help. Okay next question I am wondering your thoughts on my husband's problem. When he gets bit by any
kind of bug or gets in the poison ivy or poison oak or crate vernal tree he will have the itching
redness and swelling at the bite and contact site but then the other area is where he was not
bit nor touched by plants that he has learned to. Do you think the histamine pills would help
produce eliminate this systemic itching problem. So why would a person that why would a person be
hypersensitive to different poison this plants. Okay so most people if they get the oil on them from
poison ivy or poison oak will you know create you know their skin will be irritated by it they'll
get hives it'll be itchy and if they itch it they touch other areas they're spreading it all over.
Most people will have that experience but some people end up with a hyper reaction so they you know
it gets all over their body and it's their whole body becomes inflated. They might be they might
have been told that they're very allergic to that thing which may be true. You can your body can
develop antibodies to a toxin. So okay so let's take a step back. So when you when you're when you get
an infection so let's say you're exposed to a strep you know strep throat your daughter comes home
from school she had strep throat you breathe it in that's a bacteria so that bacteria enters your
body you end up with an immune reaction so that acute immune immune reaction is what's called a TH1
response it causes this up tick of inflammatory chemicals called cytokines your histamine response may
kick in for even a pathogen and it calls in these immune cells to kill the pathogen but let's say it's
a particularly virulent strain of strep that you've never seen before in your body and you get quite sick
and you get a fever that's a hyper TH1 response that's good because you need that TH1 response to
bring in these these immune cells to kill that pathogen and then let's say it's you know your
health wasn't really good your stress was high at that point in time and you get really sick so you
have to take the next day off of work you got a really bad sore throat but you didn't go get any
myodics you just kind of weighed through the course and you drank some chicken soup and you slowly
recovered what happens in your body is that that that TH1 response isn't able to kill it in about
24 to 48 hours it will suppress that you'll kick in this B cell response or a TH2 response and
that's responsible for making antibodies against that strep you want to do that if you have antibodies
now circulating against that strep it's going to take that strep and you're going to be able to better
kill it better even more important is now you have those circulating antibodies don't dissipate you know
they can stay with you for years and now every time let's say two months from now you get exposed
to that same strep or even a similar strain you have those antibodies to take it and you're able to
kill it quicker you never do get sick and you're like oh I have a great immune system I don't get sick
well it makes a great immune system is you have a lot of antibodies to a lot of pathogens so therefore
you never get a fever you don't feel you know because your those antibodies will take those pathogens
that you're exposed to you're still exposed to just as many pathogens as anybody else but I don't
get sick because I have these circulated antibodies that take that pathogens so my immune system could
kill it quite readily problem comes in is that when you create antibodies to things that are not
living so toxins poisons from plants poisons from our environment are not living organisms so if I
if I develop antibodies to those non-living organisms I'm going to create this inflammatory
response which is not going to be good so an inflammatory response to a toxin is not really
helpful it is said that it's going to kill the toxin because it toxins aren't killable so the
purpose of our body to create an inflammatory response to like a poison ivy is to keep us away from
going into that grove where the poison ivy was so it keeps us safe so that we won't go into
something to be exposed to a poison that could you know damage cells and you know could kill us
so that's the purpose of an inflammatory response a person that is an hyper inflammatory response
to these things may have developed antibodies if you develop i.g. g antibodies you'll end up with
this hyper response every time you're exposed to it some people even develop i.g. e antibodies which
that is a very hyper response at the time exposure that could cause all sorts of things and can
put somebody at a flactic shock and could could potentially cause death because of the inflammation
it's after exposure so that's somebody with an i.g. e reaction to peanuts per se but you can have i.g.
e reactions you can have i.g. e antibodies to mold those are the people that walk into moldy buildings
and go oh my gosh i can't take it i can't be in here i got to get out of here i got to leave
and everybody else like what is wrong with you i don't smell mold if they have i.g. e antibodies to mold
they're a hyper sensitive to mold they'll smell mold when nobody else smells mold and they got
to get out of that situation where they feel like their throat's going to close out the same thing
can be true when you're exposed to environmental things um so you so how do you deal with these things
well you try to you know that you're hyper um you you hyper inflamed to be stings you know that you
and it can be different things so let's say a deer fly some people can be hyper reacted to deer flies
but they're not hyper reacted to horse flies two different types of flies but they have different
venomous some people can be hyper reactive to poison oak but they're not hyper reacted to something
else so um you know how do you deal with this then well you once you know it you have to try to
prevent the exposure number two you should have an epiphen just to make sure that you don't have
have ever developed i.g. e reactions so you can prevent you know serious condition if you're exposed
to these things number three taking anti-histamines can be beneficial over the counter anti-histamines
medications i mean taking anti-histamines supplements can be beneficial so um what's in like our
clear histamine scavenger is quercetin and large bark and a bunch of different things that are known
to help pull these those toxins out of your body pull histamines out of your body um to calm down
mass cells mass cells are the cells that make this histamine and cause this inflammatory reaction
so long story long answer to you know what i could have done quite quickly is the answer yes these
things may help but i would also caution you you know you you you can't develop i.g. e antibodies to
things over time um if you're exposed to these things so having like an epiphen maybe a safe thing
to do as well next question is there a risk of disintegrating cancer cells um
disintegrated cancer cells going somewhere else in the body and causing problems
what happens to the cancer cells that are destroyed using a rife machine good question so if the rife
works um could you end up a cyber type reaction because only these cancer cells and it's causing
um waste from these cancer cells to um affect body um so the answer the short answer is this no this
is not going to happen and the reason is is that the rife doesn't work so there's different ways
cells die so cells can die from normal programmed cell death called apoptosis so apoptosis takes place
when a cell actually actually the term is blebbed in on itself so the cell can invert on itself and
starts breaking in part and it has actually recycled so let the cell um material inside the cell
including the cell membrane um what makes it up a cell membrane the phospholipid bilayer is
reutilized by the body reutilized by other cells so it's actually really a recycling of cell material
so what a cell is destroyed even through your t cells and your natural killer cells they stimulate
what's called an extrinsic from the outside apoptotic reaction so the cell goes through apoptosis so
you don't end up with toxins um the cell doesn't explode and cause um toxins to be dispersed in the
extracellular matrix that need to be carried away by the lymph system that takes place in a what's
called a pathological death of the cell pathological death of the cell is a process called cell
vices where the cell membrane does break apart and kind of explode and it produces a lot of
waste which are is called endotoxins waste from within and that has to be carried away
through your lymphatic system because it makes a mess in the extracellular matrix matrix that's
the matrix of fluid and waste products between cells and then that's carried away through your
lymph system that that has to go through detox pathways that is a problem when you use the
rife for killing single cell organisms so if you're using the rife to kill bacteria you can and you
will produce um endotoxins so you'll produce waste from that bacteria now it's usually not a problem
unless a person has huge um issues with their detoxification pathways unless you're killing
a certain type of bacteria called gram-negative bacteria, gram-negative bacteria,
live disease, burrelia, burgodorphia, is a gram-negative bacteria, H. Parlorism,
the gram-negative bacteria, if you kill those too quickly the other thing with gram-negative
bacteria is that they have lipopolysaccharides in their cell membranes and those liberate and those
can cause an inflammatory reaction cause what could be known as a herxide reaction but when
to answer the question when you're killing cancer cells using the rife typically using any other
natural approach you're not going to cause a herxide reaction you're not going to cause an endotoxins
to be produced you're not going to overwhelm the detox pathways so I know that you will do that
with chemotherapy chemotherapy kills cancer via lysis and through apoptosis so you can produce endotoxins
when you use chemotherapy that it can be part of why a person feels ill post chemotherapy of course
the other reason is that chemotherapy isn't going to be exclusively killing cancer cells it will be
killing healthy cells too it can damage the blood brain barrier cross the blood barrier cause inflammation
of the brain causing all sorts of things so while chemotherapy can be great to kill cancer it causes
other ill effects as well so okay next question are you familiar with factor 5 clotting disorder
yeah that's a little I think that's a lightens disorder if so how do you treat it and keep a
patient from clotting what's the effect of this of natto kinase versus lumbar kinase et cetera for
something like this so typically a person doesn't even know they have that until they end up developing
some clots and and and then they're maybe screened for that if they developed let's say
deep vein thrombosis this is the second time they've developed it then they might get screened for
that and they find out that have that so factor 5 is a genetic mutation you can have a single or
double immune double allele defect on that gene people with a double allele defect we're going to
are going to have even more difficulty and they will develop more clots at least have the chance
of it people have difficulty in pregnancy having that factor so if they've ever had clot formation
during pregnancy they will be watched and screened for that I think from a medical standpoint unless you
have a history of having clots they're not going to necessarily wreck a bed you go on a drug for this
unless you're having issues plus I think it depends on other factors other cool morbidities this
person have high cholesterol issues are they worried about possible heart issues do they have a
history of heart attack a history of cardiovascular disease things like that from a natural perspective
so what are your best anti clotting things from a natural perspective garlic so garlic is going to be
your best blood thinner your omega's can be decent blood thinner as well things like curcumin can
be a slight blood thinner garlic is going to be by far your best blood thinner far as what can
gobble up clots narrow kinase lumbar kinase are your two enzymes that you'd use to gobble up clots
there's some thought that just high dose enzymes in general can be beneficial but those two enzymes
would be the best so if I do I had that disorder I'd be taking a product with narrow kinase and
lumbar kinase in it this is a common this has been a common concern since the certain you know what
came out after that certain you know what disease came out a few years ago and when they came out with
the correction for that that involved a needle people are having all sorts of clots formations so
using a nano kinase nano lumbar kinase product using garlic can be extremely beneficial as a
preventative measure for those people the only thing that I'd say you know you can't really hurt
yourself taking garlic in at these enzymes unless you are on a blood thinner so the enzymes are
even if you're on a blood thinner but taking excess garlic if you're on a medical drug blood thinner
you really got to watch because garlic garlic works really well and I know people that got off
their blood thinners because they didn't want to be on a medication anymore so so they
they used garlic instead so you have to be careful double it up so if you're on a medical blood
thinner drug and you're using garlic you better be very leery of you know excess bleeding you know
easy bruising and all that kind of stuff so but what's worse having a little bit of easy bruising
and capillary fragility and you know that's not going to really kill anybody unless they end up with
a bleed or if they have an ulcer or something like that versus a blood clot so you do have to be
you have to weigh that all out next question my husband has four years had periods often on where
he continually burps oh it could start and then go on for several hours sometimes he has gas
build up for hours after going to bed and then goes on in the night or it could start off in the
morning at the stomach even or when he walks or exercises he lifts things any clues okay so yes my
first thought on this is he probably has a hyalurgy so I actually have a video on our website how to
help yourself with a hyalurgy so a hyalurgy is so you have a rig a muscle down at the bottom of
your esophagus that constricts it holds your stomach basically down so that rig a muscle is in the
diaphragm so you have a diaphragm that separates your lungs from your abdominal cavity but you have
things that have to go through that like your esophagus has to go through that and then your stomach sits
below the diaphragm well that rig of muscle what holds the stomach down is called a sphincter so a sphincter
holds the stomach down and it keeps it there so problem is you breathe so your diaphragm goes down
when you that's how you take a deep breath in and therefore your stomach is supposed to drop down
with the diaphragm so your stomach literally drops down in the abdominal cavity several inches every
time you take a deep breath if you have adhesions up in your neck from injuries to your neck let's say
you had an auto accident years ago or you just hurt yourself playing football or some things you have
a lot of adhesions in your neck in here that can adhere to your esophagus way up here if you have adhesions
in your diaphragm if you have weakness of that sphincter then that sphincter isn't holding the
stomach down in a part of your stomach can literally hurt you up through that sphincter that's called a
hiatal herdea hiatal is holds going the herdea through the hole in the diaphragm so a hiatal herdea
is when your stomach can hurt you up and often that part of the stomach can just bubble up there
so the top part of the stomach can bubble up in there and you can have this you know
continuous slight hiatal herdea in your stomach and then air gets trapped in there and you belch a
lot and you burp a lot you can get a lot of pain it is down there you can actually get because it's
carried on the same neurological pathways that feed your heart you can get what's called a pseudo
coronary with a hiatal herdea so a hiatal herdea can cause a pseudo coronary event so person can
feel like they're having you know a heart attack and it's actually irritation of the stomach at
the sphincter there so if you go to our website www.connorsclinic.com and you search hiatal herdea hiatal herdea
you'll see I have a blog post I actually have a video with I'm teaching my staff and
teaching one of my staff how to pull down that stomach if you have a hiatal herdea where it's
completely herdeated and it's a medical condition it's going to be much you know more serious we have
to have surgery but 99 times out of 100 it is more intermittent hiatal herdea so it can bubble up
there most the time it's tied to also a decrease in hydrochloric acid production in the stomach so
I do have a blog post on hydrochloric acid issues so look up HCl or hypochloridria look up my blog post
on that as well 9 times out of 10 hiatal herdea is tied to that hiatal herdeas are extremely common
in little babies that's why a little teeny infants can have projectile vomiting because that sphincter
isn't perfectly formed so the baby's drinking mylas melp and it just goes right up into that bubble
the bubble is called the mage and blondes and the stomach and it could literally just when the
diaphragm constricts it just shoots right out and the person can have projectile vomiting the
little baby does during that it doesn't happen in adults but they get a lot of pain down there they
get a lot of belching they feel like there's something right at the bottom of their sternum
and it is an air bubble at the bottom of the sternum that's pushing up into the diaphragm it could
become it can be very irritating so hiatal herdea functional hiatal herdea what you're dealing with
and it's something that um it just doesn't go away by itself you have to continue to work on it
continue to pull it down if you go to a chiropractor that does kinesiology they know how to fix that as well
that's not just a one-time thing you really gotta do it yourself on a regular basis as well
okay let's see if had any other questions coming while i was shutting
in and i think that is it for the day so remember to go on holistichealthour.com and you'll see all our
past episodes and they are indexed quite nicely so you should be able to find you know other questions
that we've answered um that might meet your needs also highly recommend you go on our website
we have well over a thousand blog posts our youtube channel has well over a thousand videos too
in our um our video channel that we had to create to protect ourselves from the powers that
be at youtube um has even more videos that's videos dot cuttersclimate.com all right website cuttersclimate.com
in the holistichealthour.com invites you to ask your questions thanks so much and see you next week